Transcription: eric vautier
Relecteur: Claire Ghyselen
Bonsoir, bonsoir à tous et à toutes.
Je vais commencer par vous raconter
une histoire, celle de Dany et de Carl.
Dany est au fond de son lit
et il attend que sa femme s’endorme
pour rejoindre Carl, son ami d’enfance,
dans un jeu de combat
en réalité virtuelle.
Il est impatient et excité,
car ce jeu est extraordinaire.
Ses sensations physiques, les sentiments
vécus à travers son avatar,
c’est-à-dire le personnage qui incarne
son propre corps dans ce jeu virtuel,
sont décuplés comparés
à ses capacités du réel.
Au bout d’une heure,
il se lève et se connecte.
D’habitude, ils commencent tous les deux
par échanger des coups de poing,
mais ce soir, ils préfèrent
simplement discuter.
Soudain, Carl embrasse Dany.
Et ils se mettent à avoir une relation
intime à travers leurs avatars.
Mais dès le lendemain, Dany est
très affecté par cette situation.
Au bout de quelques semaines,
ils se donnent rendez-vous physiquement
à côté de chez eux, sur un parking,
et ils s’embrassent à nouveau.
Mais il ne se passe rien.
Les émotions étaient
simplement virtuelles.
Ce que nous apprend l’histoire
de Dany et de Carl,
c’est d’abord que la réalité virtuelle
est capable de leurrer notre cerveau.
La deuxième chose,
c’est qu’il peut être dangereux
de vivre certaines situations pleinement
quand elles sont virtuelles.
Ce soir,
je vais vous présenter les risques
potentiels de la réalité virtuelle,
notamment à travers ma propre expérience
de ces environnements virtuels.
Allez, sans plus attendre, mettons
ce casque et découvrons mon avatar.
Comme vous le voyez, un avatar
peut être n’importe qui,
une créature, un monstre, un être humain.
Je peux être observateur
ou interagir avec mes propres membres
dans l’environnement virtuel.
Vous l’avez compris, c’est donc
par l’intermédiaire de ce casque
que je passe de moi à mon avatar
et par l’intermédiaire de ce dernier,
que je quitte ce monde réel
pour en rejoindre un autre.
Alors, personnellement, moi, dans la vie,
j’ai une vraie passion, c’est la pêche.
Et forcément,
dans l’immensité des jeux disponibles,
il y a forcément un jeu de pêche.
Et donc je me suis retrouvé
dans mon canapé
en train de lancer
des hameçons virtuellement
pour attraper des poissons colorés
sur une plage hawaïenne.
Waouh !
Ce qui est étonnant,
c’est que j’y ai retrouvé
tous les codes de mon activité préférée,
au point même où je me suis demandé
si je n’allais pas le ramener à la maison,
ce qui, entre nous,
aurait changé du quotidien.
Allez, changeons de décor.
Aujourd’hui, grâce à la réalité virtuelle,
nous n’avons pas besoin
de prendre l’avion.
Il suffit de prendre
un casque de réalité virtuelle
et de découvrir l’ambiance un peu caliente
du quartier chaud d’Amsterdam.
Il est possible,
grâce à la réalité virtuelle,
installé confortablement dans son canapé,
de passer d’un mode d’observateur, passif,
de fantasmes sexuels sur un écran
à un mode interactif
d’expériences érotiques immersives.
Waouh !
Grâce à l’intelligence artificielle
et aux objets connectés,
il suffit de mettre son casque,
de choisir son décor
et de reconstituer sa propre ambiance
de 50 nuances de gris.
Et puis, un jour, j’ai découvert
les réseaux sociaux en réalité virtuelle,
appelés également mondes persistants
ou métavers.
Il existe actuellement des salles
virtuelles qui permettent à des avatars
de discuter, de jouer,
d’exprimer une activité créative
dans des environnements fantasques
avec des inconnus.
Certains y vont même pour dormir.
Sérieusement ?
Il y a des gens qui mettent des casques,
qui mettent leurs capteurs,
qui s’allongent chez eux,
qui laissent ou non le micro allumé
pour en faire profiter tout le monde
et qui rejoignent d’autres corps d’avatars
dans des grands lits virtuels.
Derrière ces avatars,
ce sont de vrais individus.
Mais imaginez si demain,
ces environnements mélangent à la fois
des êtres vivants, des robots,
voire des personnes décédées.
Cela nous inciterait sûrement
à rester beaucoup plus longtemps
dans ces environnements.
D’ailleurs, des sociétés
proposent aujourd’hui
des simulations de conversations
avec des êtres disparus
en utilisant l’enregistrement
de la voix du défunt.
Toutes ces pratiques
brouillent littéralement
notre rapport à l’espace et au temps
en lien avec le deuil.
Très récemment,
des chercheurs ont permis à une mère
de revoir sa fille en réalité virtuelle,
qui était décédée déjà depuis deux ans,
en reconstituant le corps
et la voix de l’enfant.
Elle a même pu ressentir
les sensations tactiles
comme si elle touchait
réellement sa fille.
Alors, vous l’aurez compris,
il faut être conscient qu’il y a plusieurs
risques liés à la réalité virtuelle.
Le premier qui est le plus connu est
l’apparition de troubles physiques,
que ce soient des troubles visuels,
des troubles de l’orientation,
voire une fatigue mentale.
Mais à l'inverse, les deux autres sont
très peu connus ou très peu étudiés.
Ce sont des risques psycho-sociaux.
Pourtant, à travers toutes les expériences
que j’ai relatées à travers mon avatar,
que ce soient les jeux vidéo,
les jeux d’argent,
la pornographie ou les réseaux sociaux,
ce sont toutes des addictions qui sont
déjà connues, mais, vous l’aurez compris,
elles peuvent être renforcées
par justement la réalité virtuelle.
La dernière addiction,
qui est encore la moins connue,
c’est cette addiction au monde persistant,
au point de nous poser la question
si ça va nous conduire à une mort sociale.
Par mort sociale,
je parle d’un désinvestissement du réel,
c’est-à-dire que les gens préféreraient
vivre dans un monde irréel
où toutes leurs activités sociales
se feraient à travers leurs avatars.
Le plus gros danger,
c’est la perte de repères,
au point où, finalement, il y aurait
une confusion entre le réel et le virtuel,
au point d’entraîner
une altération de la perception
que l’on aurait du monde extérieur
Ou la perception
que l’on aurait de soi-même.
Finalement, comme si
soit le monde était étrange,
soit nous vivions dans un rêve.
De nombreuses choses
peuvent expliquer notamment
le fait que nous soyons addicts
à ces environnements virtuels
et le fait que l’on reste de plus
en plus longtemps exposé aux écrans.
Premièrement,
la démocratisation des systèmes.
La diminution du prix des casques, la 5G -
ah ! enfin un vrai risque de la 5G ! -
et la diversité du contenu
conduisent à cette démocratisation.
Deuxièmement, le réalisme
et l’interactivité.
Les images sont tellement de qualité
qu’aujourd’hui,
le cerveau ne fait plus la distinction
entre le vrai et le faux.
On utilise son propre corps, ses mains,
sans gants, sans capteur.
On vit vraiment la situation.
Des études en neurosciences
laissent supposer que,
lorsque l’on vit une expérience en réalité
virtuelle à la première personne,
on active des neurones miroirs
qui, finalement, renforcent
la réceptivité au contenu.
Troisièmement,
l’intelligence artificielle.
Je ne suis jamais déçu
par le contenu proposé.
La preuve : la pêche.
Et pourquoi ?
Parce que c’est de plus
en plus personnalisé.
Et enfin, quatrièmement, les émotions.
Ajouter les émotions renforce
l’incarnation dans la réalité virtuelle.
Comme vous le voyez,
il est possible aujourd’hui de capter
les expressions de mon visage,
le mouvement de mes yeux,
pour traduire une émotion chez mon avatar,
ce qui va forcément renforcer
l’interactivité dans le monde social.
Alors, si on revient à cette histoire
de Carl et Dany au début,
je ne sais pas si des sentiments
naîtront dans la réalité virtuelle,
au point où, finalement,
nous aurions plusieurs vies.
Mais il est certain qu’il est
techniquement aujourd’hui possible
de donner l’illusion à Nicolas
et à sa chienne Jeka
qu’ils sont en balade alors qu’ils sont
réellement assis chez eux.
Mais ils n’ont pas les bénéfices de
cette activité et là, ils vont s’empâter.
Il faudra sûrement attendre
une génération d’utilisateurs
pour connaître vraiment les risques
associés à la réalité virtuelle
et le nombre de personnes concernées.
Mais quoi qu’il en soit, nous devons
dès maintenant nous poser la question
d’encadrer ces activités, notamment d’un
point de vue réglementaire et éthique.
Certaines de ces expériences
pourraient même être bénéfiques.
Par exemple, le fait de revoir
sa fille en réalité virtuelle
a permis à cette mère de faire le deuil.
La question à se poser, c’est :
maintenant qu’est-ce que nous voulons
ou qu’est-ce que nous comptons en faire ?
(Applaudissements)